okay so I'm gonna give like two minutes
overview on windward you know paying for
these pizzas and years must mean
something we know it is a very unique
company in many ways it was founded
eight years ago by a me and Matan
two former Navy officers and their
vision was very unique they wanted to
bring visibility I'm talking about 2010
11 they wanted to bring visibility to
the world to the maritime world which is
was at the time kind of like the Wild
West very different for example from the
aviation world and and the company
evolved through the years and and and
what we are doing now is basically we
are integrating domain expertise from
the maritime world and data science
expertise and technology to basically
analyze marine risk and predicted we're
doing it in in two main verticals the
one that I'm going to focus on today is
the security intelligence domain just
helping basically enforcement agencies
catch the bad guys and the other
vertical which I'm not going to focus on
today but it's it's not less interesting
in terms of data science and other data
challenges is the insurance vertical
where we found that our modeling of
vessels behavior is indicative of the
chance of the propensity of a vessel to
to undergo ahead a maritime accident so
this is a something that I'm going to
briefly touch upon but I'm going to
focus mainly on the intelligence part
that's a big company because we are
doing stuff that was not done before at
least in most of these domains we are
kind of unique in the landscape people
are doing things that are similar but
not quite and and the thing is that
we're trying to integrate all this data
science and actually make a difference
and solve problems that are now under
underserved both in the insurance world
and and the and intelligence world
and I hope I'll give you a like a taste
of what it means in the next half an
hour okay so let's let's go to the main
talking finish talking about windward
let's talk about a little bit about the
quest the quest is a vessel is an
interesting vessel it's very unique it's
spent most of its life sailing in
Scandinavia I don't know if you can see
this a little bit in the midterm Union
around May May 18 2009 changed its
ownership it changed its name as it
often happens from the sea view to the
the quest it's a very old vessel built
in 1966 it's a relevant fact after its
changed ownership it started to behave
strangely what it did shortly after it
took off from Malta did this strange
voyage not entering Algeria just turning
here and going back all the way towards
here it's a it's why is it strange
because merchant vessels are economical
creatures right during this voyage with
no apparent reason seems strange with
not without entering port for example
and let me show you what happened and at
this point in this turn point let me
just comment on what's happening this is
an Italian border control but it's
called guada the financier basically
boarding a vessel the quest that we just
saw see all these helicopters and stuff
like that people with machine guns it's
a big operation they boarded the vessel
if you look you see it's kind of old
it's not maintained properly and then
they started searching obviously you do
something like that when you have a
concrete lead and finding illicit
materials on a vessel is very hard
because it's a big it's a big thing it's
three-dimensional behind the water
compartment there was a hidden
compartment with ten tons of
ich was a lot of money and and then the
quest was detained and escorted towards
a port in Italy and that is a success
story right but the problem is obviously
the Italians had a concrete lead of
what's going on on this vessel before
they launched all these massive forces
the problem is that how do you know
which one to tackle right this is the
Italian Italian territory for my thing
two days ago and it has about 40,000
vessels moving around and wouldn't be
great if if you know you had this
technological Oracle that you would
pinpoint prioritize where to look right
so instead of giving you data on 40,000
vessels that are moving around perhaps
you can narrow it down for 1% at top
half percent that's like 200 vessels
that that is something that a human
expert is more likely to be able to
cover and to look one by one and
investigate and basically drilling down
from this massive amounts of data into
something that is more concrete without
actually knowing what you're looking for
right you just want to see them on the
map and then start drilling down on the
red points which are the risky vessels
and and and try to understand why it
makes them risk in and what you should
do about it so I'm gonna tell you about
how we basically how well coloring
marking them red and yellow how we are
assessing them the amount of risk of
every vessel in the world so the outline
of the talk is basically this shortly
describing the the data platform for in
word that was built in the course of a
few weeks and then how we started
tackling that the you know building a
supervised machine learning model to to
hand to tackle the risk problems and a
little bit about modern interpretability
which is very important for us and I
think it's one of the most talked about
topics in the world of AI and machine
learning
so a little bit about the the Wynwood
platform so we like to look at it as a
pyramid as an hierarchy of data we
gather data from multiple sources I'm
going to touch briefly upon some of them
its raw data its global its historical
we have data for the last six six seven
years and the Anna's raw data usually
comes it's very dirty right it's very
noisy we need to know how to clean it
and make good use of it this is the
first layer the second layer we try to
aggregate it and create building blocks
of events right not just for example
location of a vessel or whether it's a
specific point we try to basically build
for example not event like for example
vessel entering a port that's an event
that can further King that can be
invested that can be queried for and
then can also be used to build features
for the machine learning models so the
this the upper layer is features
basically we're building a behavioral
pour files of vessels that try to
capture the ongoing pattern of operation
and the last the last one is the Machine
low models that are basically tackling
the core the the core value that
Winwood's is trying to give its clients
so let's let's talk a little bit about
the raw data the one of the most major
sources that we use is called AAS it's
automatic and it vacation system it's a
safety protocol short short range safety
protocol radio-based I'm gonna are not
going to touch about all the problems of
working with a as that that's very noisy
it's very corrupted this is an example
of a Chinese vessel that is masking its
actual course obviously it's not sailing
through the Sahara and and in Saudi
Arabia
do you know what what's the twist here
what's the manipulation can you figure
that out
yeah it's mirroring exactly this is
basically going through south of Africa
here so basically change the coordinates
of the of the latitude but not all call
of manipulations of that easy to capture
it's
very it's a very noisy data source and
we spend years of manpower
just to just to be able to walk with
this kind of data another thing that we
are very strict on is building a
coherent entities of vessels for example
this vessel that change its name like
ownership for three times and we need to
understand that although it changed its
name and some of its identifiers it's
still the same vessel it's important for
us to get the historical context of each
entity and avoid fragmentation basically
changing of ownership usually
corresponds to changing of behavior for
example these three stages of the three
ownership changes correspond to the
three different places in the world
where the vessel operated another thing
that is very important for us is the GIS
layer with the polygons layer we have
tens of thousands of polygons that are
constantly involving a changing for
example new ports are opened for example
and we need to account for that and it's
a major challenge for us to try to
maintain it you can also learn from the
movement of vessels on changing on the
mapping but I won't touch that what I
won't get into it now
other than the GIS layer we integrate
weather data it's often that strange
behavior is explained by weather for
example a vessel trying to dodge a storm
or something like that so it's a very
important context to understand the
vessel behavior so we have data for the
last five or six years and at the point
of the globe and every hour and and we
try to infer events from it so this is
the first layer of the raw data the
second layer of activities is basically
taking this this raw day that is very
hard to work with one level upwards and
building the building blocks for the
next levels so this for example is the
the first visit of the of this specific
vessel in the Suez Canal being visiting
an area for the first time it's a
deviation from your previous pattern in
life it's an interesting event for us to
tomorrow
to detect another one that is similar to
the to what we saw in the quest is more
is trying to capture this course
deviation this weird this one started
from India from Karachi went all the way
here and back and this is strange right
it's a strange voyage and what is nice
is if again if you if you make the cross
if you if you if you integrate different
data sources and you cross them you
sometimes get interesting insights for
example this is the border of the
economical zones of India so you can see
just that MIT made a u-turn just near
the border and that is very typical for
vessels doing illegal meetings with
other vessels just near the border of
the economical so another another so
some some of the events are just
algorithms or simple heuristics and some
of them are machine learning based for
example we developed a machine learning
model to detect the ship to ship ship to
ship operations it's a very interesting
thing not it's not always illegal but
you can see the pattern but the pattern
of two vessels doing some strange
pattern and then sailing next one next
to each other basically transferring
goods from one to another so this one
for example is a supervised model that
use the thousands of labeled samples to
train and to detect this this activity
this event another thing that is
interesting is vessels going dark
turning off all of their transmission
which is obviously a red flag so first
we need to detect whether they the
turning off of transmission is is indeed
an intentional thing or is it like win
awards reception problem right so we
need to detect intentional turning off
or intentional going dark and then we
need to think what to do this is a very
nice example of two vessels meeting one
another and then turning off their
transmission simultaneously which is
very interesting for us to detect and
then what we usually do we move to
another send so we are cooperating with
a very cool company called planet planet
has like
I think it's a 180 nanosatellites about
this big and they capture imagery from
the entire earth every day and they have
this very cool API you give them a
coordinates and in a time of day and
then give you the tile and when we did
this to track these two fellows we saw
we saw them both connected these are two
oil tankers part of a smuggling network
of oil from Libya to Syria we get the
entire context we know this is usually a
repeating pattern we know that one of
them continued to Syria and so on and so
forth so if we continue another
interesting thing is that is that we
sense Wiimote since we monitor the
entire globe we can look at areas and
and and infer things that's happening in
specific areas this for example is
another activity that I haven't
described of drifting in just you know
turning off the engine and and and
waiting and we can cluster them in an in
an unsupervised way to detect the common
areas of drifting right and then we
cannot detect the outliers that are
outside of these areas and that's an
interesting feature as well and or
interesting indication as well so
looking at areas is very interesting
just another example what you see here
is 'dom is the meeting operations
between fishing vessels and refills if
is are like big refrigerating vessels
that take the fish from the fishing
vessels and bring them to port and what
is very interesting here is to see this
cluster here this is no way and this is
Russia in Finland and if you again if
you put the context of the the polygons
of the economical layers you can see
that it's all happening in international
water what's basically happening that
fishing vessels go discharges of their
cargo the fish and then go back fishing
and it's usually an illegal operation
because you usually get a specific
amount and you can fish they they do it
in international water and then go back
fishing again so looking at areas can
give you strategical insights of what's
going on in the world so that's the next
layer is basically taking these events
and in calculating feature
long-term features that describe the
vessels behavior so that's moving from
you know taking one-time events and and
aggregating them to do statistics for
example the time that the vessel spends
in port or sailing over a long period of
time and this basically is the set of
features basically gives you like a
unique fingerprint or unique signature
behavior a signature of each vessel in
the world and that is the you know the
building blocks for machine learning
models an interesting thing that we can
do is basically compare each vessel to
its comparable category or its reference
populations for example we need to
compare the operation of an oil tanker
to all the old tankers in the world
right because oil tanker is very
different from a fishing vessel in its
behavior so what we usually do we just
compare the distribution or compare the
specific point relative to the
comparable category of the specific
vessel and that also gives an indication
if something is you know off or is it
the same as the rest of the similar
vessels that are operating at sea okay
so basically this now we've built we
worked hard we've built the dozens of
events we've built hundreds of features
on them and and and we have the building
lock locks to work with and now we are
able to start doing the modeling and up
up to two years ago I think mm maybe
three years ago 2016 we were somewhere
over here we had a great tool box that
drove value if you knew how to use it
all right our in-house domain expert did
marvelous thing with with the with the
with this tool box but our clients
didn't three reasons first you had to
know what you're looking for second you
need to understand the maritime domain
not all of our clients are familiar with
with all these intricacies and third one
is you had to know Winwood's data right
what does course deviation even mean so
in order to bridge the gap we thought it
would be great if we had this Oracle
this Genie that will just tell you where
to look
wanted you know to to make to compose
complicated queries that note I don't
know what the what the pattern is really
is I just want you to tell me right and
then we started a side project I can
talk about but about the side project
evolved but I'll just go over briefly we
started with a mock as part of the
planning usually people don't do it it
just rush to start optimizing or start
working or coding as an a big part of
the planning phase is actually imagining
how the end result would look like and
we thought that if we had this Oracle
this genie that would give ranks risk
ranking for every vessel in the world
that would be great and the distribution
would probably look like this and then
we thought what would interest our
client so it's this probably this long
tail right our law enforcement customers
are not interesting in there
well behaving vessels which are most of
the world they're interesting in the
cream of the crop and so after the mall
end and this is very important because
it focuses on what to optimize right now
implementation metric is very important
and it can be derived from this other
thing that we're to measure and decide
on is is for example we knew that we
wanted to do to be precision oriented
right because if you give a tip for a
clue to a client and he send a
helicopter and there's nothing there
then he'll be pissed but if he if you
don't give him a lead that's that
actually had the drugs you won't blame
you that you didn't catch everything so
we knew what that we had to be precision
oriented we had to talk about latency I
mean how dynamic the score will be and
all this kind of consideration that you
really helps to focus you during the
project the problem is that we started
with no label data at all there is no
easy sources of you know for example
smuggling databases that you can obtain
it's really hard and then what what do
you do so first of all you start
gathering you know blog posts news news
sites start calling the web and start
gathering and then you decide you just
have to start simple I think the the the
first version had like eight features
and we did the collinear combination of
them and just sorted and ranked them and
then we showed it to one of our domain
experts we sitting here amid and other
the top thirty that we showed him in you
like twenty right and if you show it the
domain expert so I know this I know this
vessel I know this vessel its first a
good sign that you're on track and and
also occurred to us that instead of just
using them to confirm perhaps we can use
them to generate label data right so
even if it's the subjective opinion it's
pretty close to to reality most
smuggling cases for example are never
caught so we had a lot of challenges of
how to deal with it we had many people
in-house experts creating a naval data
we generated a feedback loop form within
the product for internal users to be
able to mark a specific vessel as risky
or not or not risky in a effortless
manner and then we had to clean this
subjective labeling in in different ways
for example we had a super in inspector
that actually we made personal comments
and and all the tags and and threw some
garbage out but anyway this subjective
labeling gave us a huge boost with
respect to our ability to develop the
supervise model one of the challenges
that we had to tackle is that we had
many training examples once we gathered
a few hundreds of cases we had like many
training examples from different points
of time like smuggling in 2015 and we
had to generate all the feature space as
of 2015 right because that's the the
point where we're interesting in the
behavior and we had many you know many
sparse examples enough in the time
continuum but the online prediction goes
everyday we wanted a continuous
prediction to walk in in batches every
day and and sometimes the engineering
here is different if you want random
access you go to databases if you want
like prediction and huge amounts of data
maybe you should use other methods one
of the things here is that this is very
biased with respect to this so for
example the amount
most 99 of the vessels are behaving well
right but our training set was very
biased towards the risky vessels so you
have you had to correct for that in some
manner so one of the things that we try
to do so we had a problem you know late
manually labeling a good vessel is
boring I mean they're just acting like
vessels there's nothing interesting
happening and there's a limited amount
of you know normally behaving vessels
that you can give a person to tap for
you it takes time and effort if it's
something interesting then is it's all
in it I mean wow that's the interesting
and that's risky so what we did we just
try to random sample the population if
99% are indeed good so let's just random
randomly take most of them and give them
a label of of negative or well behaving
it might hurt a little bit the signal
but it might also help the model the
things that we didn't take into account
is that random sampling is hard to do in
a truly random way and we just took a
batch of vessels random vessels from a
specific date and it turns out that it
beta bites us of course we saw too good
to be true results right you need to
develop the intuition where it can be
that good right it's very important in
data science and then we dig in a little
bit saw the future importance of some
features and then we saw that some of
our features are time-dependent right
for example the feature that we had how
many days the vessel exists in your
system is slowly shifting to the right
as you go through the years right it's
the same distribution just shifted to
the right and what the mode the model
did it basically exploited this leakage
right this feature enabled the model to
to learn the specific date where most of
the data is negative and it just
exploited the leakage so we need to add
to fix the feature and we also fix fixed
a random or a sampling process to be
more random on different dates but
that's something to be aware of to be
careful and then another thing that we
understood is that we are not really we
don't really want it to say yes or no
and we are
afraid to give probabilities for the
events it's really you know presumptuous
to say this vessel has 27% of smuggling
now so what we did we used a classifier
to rank right
we took the probabilities of the model
for example the extra boost classifier
that we trained and basically rank the
entire population and then took the top
X percent let's say a prior of 1% of the
population is interesting and just
ranked it and took the top 1% or X
percent walking with XD boost when you
want to rank X to possess like tons of
parameters you can optimize it and tune
and 2 of them is really interesting so
first is the eval metric so remember I
told you showed you the mock so rocket
you see is not a good metric if you want
to if you aren't all interesting in the
you know the edge of the distribution
right no one is interested in if you are
you know sorting the the middle of the
of the population so one thing that you
can do you can replace the rocket you
see eval metric of the extra boost to a
custom function that actually does it
right takes the top 5% 2% 1% and checks
precision on that for example and
another thing that is worth playing
around with is changing the objective
function for something more suitable to
ranking and not for example I think the
don't remember the default I think it's
logistic I think it's binary logistic
for the objective function just to
remind the objective function is the
function that the boosting algorithm
calculates in each iteration when it
builds the next tree so we had to play a
little bit around with that and and
another thing that we saw is that the
world is changing we did the the model
on different time there and different
time points and we saw that there is a
slow gradual decline in the this is the
percentage the different percentage this
is the 90th percentile of the
predictions and it's slowly decreasing
and there are a couple of explanation
here couple of explanations here one is
the the features bias that I just showed
you if you have features that are slowly
decaying or shifting the distribution
that can explain that and the other
explanation is that
sometimes the population is changing so
for example if we inserted a lot of good
or safe vessels then the percentages
will also shift okay so just to see that
you're not falling asleep midterm quiz
to check your intuition what do you
think is the most discriminating feature
that will unable to detect smuggling for
example the vessel age the number of
countries that it visited the type or
the size of the vessel I think the type
is very interesting but the actual
number the actual the actual answer is
the number of countries well it turns
out that local vessels don't smuggle
right they don't leave the country and
that's a lot of it's a big part of the
population
it seems trivial but this is the thing
that you say that you never you couldn't
fail father couldn't think of it
beforehand and then you sit in the data
and so now it's trivial of course of
course it's a stone feature but no one
knows it in advance
a little bit about modern interpreter
bility it's a very huge thing especially
last year how many of you know lime
heard of lime okay most schapp okay
fewer so a little bit about modern
intelligibility in general so first it's
obvious why our modern needs explanation
right if you were gonna Ray the vest in
the middle of the ocean you need to
understand why if you are trying to
insure a vessel or not ensure a vessel
you need to understand why it's risky
and it's the same for every a critical
decision making based on machine
learning model in med medical domains
and so on so I like to divide it into
two so first the first is the technical
debugging tool for data scientist and
the second is a is the product
integration for the end-user I'm gonna
talk a little bit for about shape which
is a technical tool for the data
scientist to inspect its model so shop
basically is an algorithm that lets you
understand the impact of every feature
every specific feature on a specific
example I don't have time to expend
exactly how it works but basically it
calculates
there's a great book about
interpretability here which I suggest
you guys read it's not just about Shep
about the topic in general basically it
just calculates different permutations
of the different features and compared
them with the features in it tend to
understand the contribution of the
feature that it isolates basically runs
many experiments it has very nice
properties for example completeness what
it does is all the shape values or the
contributions of features generate when
you sum them up it's basically the
distance from the average prediction so
either to upwards or downwards dummy
means basically if it doesn't effect the
prediction the shape value will be zero
and additive 'ti means that you can take
shape values of different of different
algorithms and add them for example if
you are it's very good for three based
model for example random forest if you
averaged different decision trees you
can concurrently in parallel calculate
share values and for every three and
just sum them up together just to show
you how it works so basically this is
the codes a very simple code works very
well with most of the SQL models so what
you see here this is the average this is
the average prediction of the model and
this is the actual prediction for a
specific sample so this is the quest
which is was very dangerous but the
vessel that we started with and all the
red ones are pushing the prediction to
the right and all the blue ones are the
good the good fit could behave well
behaving features that are pushing the
predictions towards the safer area and
you see that the red ones are bigger and
indeed the build here that we talked
about it's an old vessel it's more
disposable it's a risk indicator pushing
it to the right it visited new places
pushes it to the right and so on so it's
a very good tool for data scientists to
expect specific samples similar to what
you're doing with lime but I think it's
even more you know is it too to
understand another another thing that
you can do is basically inspect inspect
the entire data set so for example what
you see here is the shape value versus
the feature value to see correlations or
the gradient or the correlation between
the future value and the contribution to
the model so for example if I take the
turning off transmission the going dark
if you don't if you don't do it meaning
that the future value is low then you're
good negative shaft value if you're
doing it and it becomes red meaning the
uto contributing to the risk so the so
if you have monotone ease features
that's easy
some features are more complexed for
example it's red in both in the middle
it's safe then you need to understand
what's going on
maybe it's dependent in other features
and you can do also all sorts of
dependence plot with shap it's a very
useful tool I I suggest you guys just
beep install it and you will discover
interesting things in your models just
to sum up so basically I just described
the Winwood's Data Platform is a
hierarchical hierarchical way to work
with rogue data you just build the
building blocks then you create features
from them talked a little bit of
interesting challenges that we had when
he we just started this risk modeling
project of doing imbalance data with no
label data at the beginning and the shop
is an inspection tool for modern
interpretability just want to thank the
team all of them contributed to the work
and the specific presentation i would
specifically want to mention there johan
will who was an intern who started the
project in its early stages with me and
norm which is the our chief domain
expert you can say that the risk mode
that is the most similar to her brain
because he is responsible to most of the
the samples we're also hiring a senior
data scientist and our technical data
analyst so if you know someone that is
looking to do really meaningful
interesting stuff talk to us there are
many Windward people in the crowd if you
want to see the system during the break
see act the actual things that we're
doing you're more than welcome and I'll
be happy to take any questions that you
have
yeah okay so the bottom layer of the raw
data it's like hundreds of million
hundreds of million data points a day
it's in GB bytes is I don't know
and radhika bites a day but one of the
challenges is that we need to calculate
all the historical data in retrospect so
for example if we generated a new
algorithm we want its prediction on the
entire history for all vessels in the
world so what we do basically every
weekend we just rely on history again
although the algorithms are recalculated
on the historical data sometimes it's
it's a big it's a huge engineering
engineering challenge but it enables us
to improve the algorithms and then enjoy
you know the the fruits on a global and
historical so it depends with the risk
model for example style with no label
data so you need just you know very
strong and and then and simple features
that might show a signal so it's usually
in the end models it could be tens tens
of features and the insurance and the
dad said it depends on so again how many
smuggling events so it's a few thousands
yeah but it took us a lot to reach that
yeah what do you do with all the AI yes
ships there are a bunch yeah so
basically that was the bread of butter
of Windward the past few years we have
algorithms to detect which which vessel
is manipulating it's a is to throw away
noisy data points it's a lot of
algorithmics involved it's a and it's a
and we have also an hybrid system in
which where we are not so sure I mean
the algorithm cases that are very
difficult then we give in to a human
expert so we have a human expert going
of over about I don't know 30 40 cases
of AIS manipulations a day which are
very hard to a good for the algorithm to
decide what's happening and it just
gives us feedback to the to the system
it's pervasive per time so it's possible
for a vessel to appear more than once in
the dataset can you capture interaction
between different vessels yes so I
haven't we have a very nice project of
basically taking this feature space you
can call it ship Tuvok right
representing the behavior of the vessel
in a vector that's what it is and then
we can do some very neat things with it
for example you know you cannot do some
K nearest neighbor and get similar
behaving vessels to the one that you are
actually investigating you can do
clustering an outlier detection when you
have this n dimensional signature so
yeah we're looking at interactions you
can we are doing a little bit of graph
analysis I just didn't have time to show
the the full stack
[Applause]